[Music]
it's time to introduce myself
[Music]
just three ounces of pressure to the
vagus nerve and then look at your boy
sleepy night night Blanche sterling the
legendary spy who's always dressed to
impress
Walter Beckett graduated MIT at 15 and
works in the tech innovations lab there
are so many gadgets I want to test in
the field for example the inflatable
hook kind of a personal protection
device I've been developing this is a
vile waste of taxpayer dollars this is
your next objective none of our agents
can get close to him
[Music]
I have something that can help it's
called biodynamic concealment imagine if
I can make you disappear hey Lance look
at me look at you I could see my butt
and your face at the same time that is
so cool being a pigeon could make you an
even better spy pigeons are everywhere
nobody notices them and as you can see
it's slow motion
that was tight did anyone else see a
pigeon and kitchens can fly up to 92
miles per hour don't you probably
officers you'll figure it out
all right Kimora starting it's about to
get messy time to go slippy night-night
I miss my hands I gotta stay you're
squeezing through Oh what happens in a
submarine stays in a submarine
[Music]